what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Ghost Rider which all of
you all seem to love and I think you
guys are really gonna love the way this
comic book ends the way this story arc
ends it's really really awesome so what
this does here is again this kind of
continues on the journey that we've had
so far and as always you'll find a link
to the Ghost Rider playlist down in the
description but it follows the Journey
of like Johnny Blaze right now again one
of the things that we talked about in
the first couple videos and one of the
things that I think is worth reiterating
here is that unlike in years past when
Johnny Blaze and the Ghost Rider kind of
worked in tandem one of the big issues
that he's contending with right now is
that the relationship between himself
and Ghost Rider is very similar to like
Bruce Banner and the Incredible Hulk in
the early days of Marvel Comics Johnny
Blaze turns into the Ghost Rider but he
doesn't recall anything the Ghost Rider
does and he might wake up days or even
weeks after becoming the Ghost Rider and
just kind of have to pick up the pieces
now there is going to be something
really cool that Benjamin Percy throws
into the story that's really going to be
fun but again a lot of this deals with
kind of getting Johnny Blaze back to his
roots right that now that he's kind of
back to being the Ghost Rider it's
really more him boots on the ground that
he's sort of out there in the world
dealing with all this devilry and all
that kind of crazy stuff and so one of
the things that happens is he talks
about what's called the Red Road and the
Red Road is called that because it's
this road where seemingly anytime
anybody travels it they ultimately die
in some capacity animals that run across
the road will ultimately end up being
killed right people will go on the road
right they'll head on a road trip and
they'll drive down the Red Road and
they'll never make it to their
destination no one will ever know where
they went to but there's rumors that
kind of circulate around out there now
the big question you have to ask here is
that if nobody ever survives then how
are the rumors getting out there but the
big thing the the cool thing like comic
book logic just kind of run with it
one of the things that that happens here
is that Johnny Blaze basically gets a
ride with a hitchhiker now of course
that begs the question if you're walking
down a road where seemingly everybody
who's on that road dies why would you
get into a car with a stranger right but
again one of the things you remember is
that he's literally imbued with a being
that's powerful enough to challenge some
of the strongest Cosmic entities in
existence he just largely hangs out on
Earth and so what ends up happening is
that the the way the stories go is that
those individuals who drive down this
road will ultimately be met by like a
truck and this truck is almost kind of
powered by demon energy or something
like that so for those of you guys who
remember Stephen King's Maximum
Overdrive think that right but instead
of it being potentially aliens or some
unanswered cause it's quite literally
just kind of a demon-controlled vehicle
but the the reality here is that we're
initially Johnny Blaze sees a truck and
then believes that like this is the the
truck that you know kills people and so
on then of course it ends up just being
a truck that's transporting a whole
bunch of sheep but as he starts talking
to this guy this guy's really really
fascinating right he basically starts
asking him like what's your name and and
where do you come from and that kind of
thing and he says that like these these
roads here right things like the Red
Road that when the time came when like
the interstate system right the highway
system was built to transport people
from one state to another those were all
done for convenience and it may very
very easy to travel right in between
states and so that meant that roads like
this ended up just becoming back roads
that at one point they were highly
traveled roads but nobody really travels
them anymore and so roads like that are
so dangerous and so he's really kind of
leaning into the idea that there is
something off about the Red Road the
problem with this is that as they end up
making their way over to or at least
kind of continue driving they end up
coming across like the truck that was
transporting all these sheep that was
involved in a massive car wreck along
with another passenger vehicle and
seemingly everybody was killed and
that's when this driver reveals that
like he has been tasked by the Red Road
to sacrifice somebody because if that
person isn't sacrificed by this guy this
guy will die to the Red Road so it's
almost kind of like a curse it sort of
goes from one person to the next of
course Johnny Blaze isn't having any of
that smash this guy's head into the
steering wheel and helps them understand
his place in the bigger picture but
following that of course that's when you
get the hell truck that shows up here
now what's kind of funny is that there
is a driver who survives seemingly the
driver of the sheep truck right the one
that's transporting sheep and Johnny
Blaze basically get some safety but one
of the things that happens here is that
Johnny Blaze transforms into the Ghost
Rider and literally tells the guy you
don't want to be here for this and then
we switch because what Johnny Blaze says
is that he doesn't really remember
anything that happened there now this is
one of the coolest things I love about
this story years and years ago right
when Marvel would when they first
introduced The Ghost Rider and even
running up into the in the 1990s when
you had like the midnight Suns and that
kind of thing the Ghost Rider was almost
kind of front and center and Johnny
Valles was sort of a background
character what I love that they're doing
here is they're making Johnny Blaze a
foreground character and giving us just
enough of the Ghost Rider to show us the
kind of stuff that he can do but the
reality here is that I think focusing on
Johnny and then kind of the Ghost Rider
second is a way to actually build up
interest in the character as opposed to
turning it into what is basically an
Incredible Hulk book which is if the
Hulk's not smashing things I don't care
and it's a way you actually kind of keep
interest in Ghost Rider as a whole but
again we kind of get this explanation of
what the Ghost Rider does because
nothing would be complete without
showing us the Ghost Rider smashing
effects and so what ends up happening
and probably one of the coolest things
that I think I've ever seen the Ghost
Rider literally conjures a hell truck
like it conjures an entire truck just
fashioned from by like Health flames and
reality warping and the truck looks
amazing and then it just like crashes
under the hell truck and like that's it
like we we never find out what what went
on there now given all the context of
the stuff that we've talked about so far
we can largely presume that like the
truck was controlled by a demon and like
Johnny Blaze or at least the Ghost Rider
destroyed the demon and like that's
basically the end of that but following
this one of the things to know is that
we kind of have to talk about Talia War
Road because again she's the character
that was introduced in this story that's
working alongside the FBI to track down
Johnny Blaze now they're doing that
because they don't have all the cards
and they don't fully know everything
that's going on all they're really aware
of is the fact that the Ghost Rider
really Johnny Blaze's return mysterious
stuff seems to happen in you know around
him and you know basically weird things
having happened after he was there here
and so that's it right now Talia War
Road is very much tied into like the
occult mysticism things along those
lines but she seems fairly new to it all
in so far as the Ghost Rider and all
that because she hasn't quite put the
pieces together now in reality it's one
of the cool things about this say for
example this story involves like The
Avengers or something like that they
would know exactly what's going on and
that's one of the things that I love
about this is that it it's a part of the
Marvel the Marvel Comics universe but it
almost kind of feels separated from it
now that's going to change as we get
towards the end of this video because
you're going to see a lot of of cameos
from just amazing characters that you
know and love
for Marvel Comics but one of the things
that had also gone on in the first issue
of the Ghost Rider run as we were met
with a guy named zebediah who showed up
in the town where Johnny Blaze was being
held albeit without knowledge that he
was a Ghostwriter he was literally a
prisoner of demons in a local town and
zebediah told him nothing that you see
is real and set Johnny Blaze in the path
of freeing himself from the town and
then basically the return of the Ghost
Rider we didn't know anything about Zeb
and we still kind of don't the only
thing that we're aware of is that he is
part of a group called the Council of
night magicians and by and large they
seem to either be working with or
against Johnny Blaze in Ghost Rider were
not entirely sure the only thing we know
and the only real reason we even get
this is because of the fact that it's
designed to show that the night
magicians as a group were the ones who
were working to free Johnny Blaze but we
don't know what their motivation is but
that is an important thing to mention
here because it does give context to the
character of Zeb and will likely become
something that's very important later on
down the line for the character of Talia
one of the things that's really really
cool about her is she gives a little bit
more of her backstory and again because
War Road is such an enigmatic character
and because we don't know a whole lot
about her any little bit of her origin
story to me has been fascinating and so
what she says is that when she was a kid
she used to be scared of the dark right
because the dark showed her bad things
and we've learned about that before
right that like she told her teacher
that like she had cancer before the
teacher even knew that when the teacher
went and got checked they discovered she
had cancer and the teacher constantly
took it out on Talia but one of the
things is that because she was so
terrified of the dark instead she
decided to confront it and because the
dark would like tell her things right
bad things that were happening to people
so on and so forth when she confronted
the dark she realized it was really just
her powers right seemingly the nature of
her and so that seems to indicate at
least on some level how what is she
gained her abilities I mean clearly a
lot of this was really just metaphor if
anything else and I'm sure we'll
actually get a full-on understanding of
exactly how her powers work and what all
goes on there but following this we get
into what's probably one of the cooler
parts of the story which is basically
John Blaze waking up in a hotel bathroom
I'm sorry a gas station bathroom no
that's not the cool part
um I mean I can't imagine anything cool
about waking up in a gas station
bathroom but what ends up happening is
the Ghost Rider leaves kind of burned on
the ceiling exit 666. now that's one of
the things that he talks about here is
that because Johnny Blaze doesn't really
remember everything the Ghost Rider does
that what the writer will do is he'll
actually burn clues in writing on like
the ground or the walls or the ceiling
or something along those lines and it's
up to Johnny Blaze to figure out what it
is the rider wants him to do so it is
cool and it's kind of fascinating the
way this works but what ends up
happening is he ends up right you know
traveling to this exit he ends up at a
town called Thorne out there in South
Dakota and that in this town there's
like literally Flyers everywhere that
say come see the circus right the circus
has come to town and so following that
he ends up kind of following the clues
and ends up at another place seemingly
out there in the middle of nowhere in
Minnesota and that when he gets there
that there's literally this giant tent
and there's like these circus guys that
are in there and there's almost
something out of Stephen King's It Right
like literally they're not really clowns
so much as it is like a circus guy and
like people are there but what they what
he says is like the tent would appear at
Sunset there was no announcement on the
radio or in the newspaper no warning
except the faint sound of calliope music
riding the breeze the people came anyway
they walked away from open cash
registers and running baths they left
their cars running and their dinners
have finished on the table and so
they're kind of operating under a trance
of sorts and as they get in there they
just kind of do whatever it is that like
they're told to do right led by the main
magician himself now those are the guys
who see like those of you guys who are
familiar with the Ghost Rider Mythos you
know exactly who this is and it's one of
the craziest things like I love the way
that Benjamin Percy did this because as
soon as I saw that I was like is that
who I think it is and literally this guy
just kind of hypnotizes the different
people of the town to like go up and do
the flying trapeze and then like jump to
their deaths they all pile into a car
and they're crushed to death or like
they put their head in the mouth of a
lion and they're eaten alive like
they're burned to death by fire and so
is Johnny Blaze kind of rides through
and then transforms into the Ghost Rider
he shows up at this circus or at least
the most recent location of this circus
where everybody in the town has been
destroyed but then he confronts
basically the demon force that still
seems to be there which initially
manifests in the forms of like an
amorphous blob of all these people kind
of operating in unison but then takes on
the actual form of the circus of KRON
now the circus of crime in Marvel Comics
they're they were never a serious team
like they were never ever ever a group
that you ever took seriously right like
for like to give you guys perspective
here imagine the least important
Spider-Man villain ever and then imagine
that he made a team of equally
unimportant people and that's the circus
of crime right that's literally what the
circus of crime is and so it's kind of
wild because like Johnny Blaze tells
like these demonic forces leave while
you can and the circus of crime
basically stays but one of the first
things he hits at is he's like you're
not who you're supposed to be right like
I know who you are I recognize you all
you're a small time crime group you
don't do things like this you don't like
destroy entire towns full of people like
by forcing them to kill themselves and
all that kind of stuff what in the world
is going on and they simply say you're
not who you claim to be either Johnny
and then ultimately they literally wipe
his mind right like the lead guy uses
his uh uses his hypnosis I can never
remember his name but this the guy with
like the top hat and everything he's
always been the leader of the circus of
crime he was always the guy running the
show but I can never ever ever remember
this dude's name and honestly it doesn't
it doesn't really matter ring Master
that's what it is it's ring Master uh
God I was I was going crazy trying to
remember this guy's name but ultimately
like he uses his uh his hypnosis to
seemingly kind of knock Johnny Blaze out
or at least put him to sleep and then he
just kind of wakes up out in the middle
of nowhere and like that's basically it
and so the next warning that he gets or
at least the next uh piece of
information that he gets from Ghost
Rider is three days hell's backbone
rally ride or die and this is when
things get awesome so here's what
happens right it's one of the coolest
things ever right so Johnny Blaze gets
to this town you'll notice we're kind of
rushing through everything because
honestly I want to get to like the
really cool stuff right the really
really awesome thing so what he says is
he says when I was a kid I had trouble
controlling myself right tantrum doesn't
feel like an adequate work I'd hit I'd
bite I'd get red-faced and wild-eyed I'd
cry or I'd scream in a way that sounded
like howling the wolf found you right
quote unquote if you ever rage so hard
your body won't stop shaking you got
some small sense of what I go through
every time I change and he says every
time I become the Ghost Rider and he
says the wolf Finds Me And It Claws and
drags all these terrible feelings out of
me turning me inside out and demanding
to be heard now the question is who's
the real me the guy who keeps all that
swallow down or the guy who goes crazy
and he says I'd like to blame everything
that's gone wrong in my life on the
spirit of Vengeance but we always like
to blame someone else or something else
for our Worst Behavior and so he says
the writer told me to come here to
Escalante Utah or beg me I'm not really
sure ride or die that's what the message
etched in molten asphalt told me we've
traveled a long way to get here we're
barely holding on flaring in and out
like a bad spark plug we can't speak for
both of us but I get the sense we're
counting on this being the end of the
road here's a crazy thing once he gets
there there are some of the most notable
names when it comes to like magic and
sorcery and all kinds of stuff that are
here people that you've you've seen
multiple times and it seems like it's
only a matter of time before you ended
up seeing this thing right so literally
it's like a giant Mo like a like a biker
race you've got man thing Doctor Doom
blade Wolverine Moon Knight like they're
all here and it's kind of nuts right now
the question has to be asked why are
they all here right now cool thing is we
get that question answered right he
literally says you'd only know about the
hell's backbone rally if you hung out in
the wrong kind of bars and truck stops
and internet chat rooms it's almost like
a collective mystical whisper around us
and Drew us here a prize has been
promised if you ride hell's backbone
from tail to Horns you get to hold
counsel with the devil and he'll give
you anything you wish for somebody
looking for trouble or somebody looking
for Penance or somebody who isn't afraid
to fight gods and demons that trophy is
worth whatever hairpin turns and deadly
drops lie ahead and that's the crazy
thing is because they're all literally
competing against each other to gain a
wish from the devil and it's I mean this
is like a No Holds Barred thing right
this is literally what was that
motorcycle road rash this is like road
rash from the 1990s those of you guys
remember that video game way back then
it's like that right like I mean do
whatever you have to do to win right you
can literally screw up other people's
bikes you can attack them you have have
like Blade versus Dracula you've got
Jamie Madrox the multiple man I mean you
have all kinds of stuff here all kinds
of people here using their powers their
abilities the whole nine yards it's
pretty awesome to see this happen now of
course ultimately Johnny Blaze catches
up to Wolverine and as he rides by
Wolverine realizes Johnny blazes back
he's like holy cow Johnny Blaze is here
and that's the crazy thing because as
they continue their ride suddenly the
road starts to come to life right like
literally this hell Road starts coming
to life and like seizing control of
people grabbing people you have like
this giant Loop that they all have to go
through and as they do the road and like
all these demonic beings just start
snatching people out of the air right
that's literally it it's kind of nuts
now whether or not they all die I'm not
entirely sure I mean I imagine people
who are here like Loki or somebody like
that they can escape right they can use
their magic to get away or something
along those lines but for like the
average person who's just like this
sounds like a fun biker race and has no
clue what they're getting into yeah man
they're going they're it's it's the end
of the road for them right they're done
with all their living whether they know
it or not
and so what's nuts here is that as
Johnny Blaze goes through this he starts
to realize this is not a race this is
not what's going on here it's not some
race to gain the devil's favor that was
done to get everybody out here it's a
recruitment Gathering right like he says
there's nobody here who hasn't eaten
their share at the sin Buffet why should
hell wait for us when we'll gladly
deliver ourselves right to the devil he
says by coming here we've unknowingly
been enlisted in an army of Shadows it
doesn't matter if anybody makes it to
the horned peak of the mountain nobody
wins tonight and so where crossbones
ends up taking out the uh the wheel of
Johnny Blaze right ends up taking out
like the back wheel of his bike Johnny
Blaze in turn crashes cracks his head on
the ground and literally a demon starts
exiting out of his head and so like
while he's there right where this demon
just seemingly kind of seizing control
of him wolf range shows up and then
Wolverine rescues them right like
literally throws them on the back of the
bike and that's when he's when literally
Johnny Place tells wolverine look man
you and I have swam in the same Pond
multiple times right like we've been in
the same area you've sure you do X-Men
you do Avengers stuff but like you're a
man of the world you've experienced
demons and Sorcerers and monsters and
Thanos and all kinds of crazy things so
understand me when I tell you we have to
close this road that if you pass through
that exit you are or at least through
that tunnel you're gonna end up in the
service of the devil and there's not
going to be any conceivable means for
you to escape it and so ultimately
Wolverine knowing Johnny Blaze as he
does ends up basically sending his bike
flying to the uh to the the entrance and
then they ultimately destroy the bike
and then collapse the entrance the
problem is that in the midst of all this
suddenly Johnny Blaze ends up being
taken in by the forces of the devil
right literally pulled in and that's
when we switch over to the person
watching all this right seemingly the
being that organized all of this and it
says I tried to give you a good quiet
life and you rejected that for violence
of course the original prison of Johnny
Blaze is what's being referred to here
and then it says so I tried to enlist
your violence for a grander purpose but
you rejected that too if you're not
going to join us in our path to a shadow
country then I block heart will have to
end Johnny Blaze and the Ghost Rider
Blackheart being none other than the son
of Mephisto himself with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you all for watching and I'll
catch you all later
peace